COULD BE DESIGNATED AS THIS
AGGRESSOR STATE.
>>
TASHA, GREAT REPORTING, THANKS
SO MUCH.
>>> JOINING ME IS DAVID SANGER,
A WHITE HOUSE AND NATIONAL
SECURITY CORRESPONDENT FOR "NEW
YORK TIMES," AND RETIRED GENERAL
MARK HERTLING.
DAVE, FIRST NATASHA WAS
REPORTING, WHAT ARE YOU HEARING
ABOUT THIS AGGRESSOR STATE
DECIDINGATION?
>> WELL, ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH NAMING THEM AS A STATE
SPONSOR OF TERROR, THOUGH THEY
WOULD CERTAINLY FIT THE BILL,
GIVEN THE ATTACKS ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE, THEN IT TRIGGERS
A WHOLE SERIES OF ADDITIONAL
SANCTIONING SOME OF THIS MAY
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO HAVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY IN HOW YOU DEAL
WITH FINANCIAL TRANSFERS, SO THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS TRYING TO
AVOID THAT, BUT STILL GET
CONGRESS A WAY TO SORT OF VENT
THEIR VIEWS ON RUSSIA.
THIS IS THE WORDING.
IT WOULD CARRY WITH IT A SENSE
OF THE CONGRESS, BUT REALLY
WOULD NOT TRYINGER -- TRIGGER
ANY KINDS OF ACTION.
IT'S NOT AN UNFAMILIAR PROBLEM.
>> GENERAL, WHEN IT COMES TO
ACTIONABLE SUPPORT FROM THE
UNITED STATES, WHICH IS WHAT
UKRAINE IS LOOKING FOR, OF
COURSE, DO YOU SEE THE
DECIDINGATION SIGNIFICANT AT
ALL, OR JUST WINDOW DRESSING
?
>> JUST LISTENING TO YOUR REPORT
THAT SOME CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS
SAY PRESIDENT BIDEN ISN'T
HOLDING RUSSIA ACCOUNTABLE, THAT
IS A LUDICROUS STATEMENT BECAUSE
OF THE PREVIOUS THINGS THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE AGAINST
THE RUSSIA STATE, BUT THIS GIVES
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION MUCH MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN WHAT THEY CAN AND
CAN'T DO.
I THINK HE'LL CONVINCE PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY THAT THIS IS THE BEST
APREACH TODAY.
>> DAVID, DID THIS ALSO -- IT IS
WHAT IT IS -- THIS IS A BIG DEAL
THAT ZELENSKYY IS COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES FOR THIS MEETING
AND HIS REMARKS, LEAVING HIS
COUNTRY FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
THE RUSSIAN INVASION BEGAN.
WHAT DOES TODAY'S WHITE HOUSE
MEETING AND ADDRESS TO CONGRESS
MEAN?
>> THE FIRST AND MOST IMPORTANT
SYMBOLIC EVER, ZELENSKYY WAS NOT
TO BE ALIVE ACCORDING TO THE
RUSSIAN PLAN.
SO THE VERY FACT THAT HE'S
SHOWING UP IN THE OVAL OFFICE,
AND THEN ADDRESSING A JOINT
SESSION OF CONGRESS IS REALLY
MEANT AS A MESSAGE TO SORT OF
DRIVE HOME THE HUMILIATION OF
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY FOR THEIR
INABILITY TO TAKE OVER UKRAINE.
SECOND, IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A
THANKS.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS AT
TIMES BELIEVE THAT ZELENSKYY WAS
NOT SUFFICIENTLY GRATEFUL FOR
WHAT HE'S GETTING.
THIRDLY, IT'S SUPPOSED TO WHIP
UP SOME SUPPORT FOR CONTINUED
AID, BUT THEN I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS TO SORT OF
TURN A CORNER, KATE, AND GET
PEOPLE ACCUSTOMED TO THE FACT
THIS WOULD BE A VERY, VERY LONG
WAR.
THAT MEANS MOVING TO A POSITION
OF SUPPORTING UKRAINE FOR YEARS,
NOT JUST FOR MONTHS.
>> AT A MOMENT WHEN THERE WILL
BE A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE PURSE STRINGS AND
WHO CONTROLS THE PURSE STRINGS
IN WASHINGTON.
THAT COULD BE PART OF IT AS
WELL.
HE WILL BE SPEAKING NOT JUST TO
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITIES IN
CONGRESS, BUT TO A REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY WHEN TALKING ABOUT
LONG-TERM SUPPORT FOR YOU'VE
CRANE.
GENERAL, THIS WEEK -- HEY, CAN I
TACK TO WHAT DAVID SAID?
>> OF COURSE.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WHAT
DAVID SAID.
THIS IS NOT ONLY FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF EMBARRASSMENT OF
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY, BUT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY WAS JUST ON
THE BATTLE FRONT GIVING AWARDS
TO SOLDIERS.
HE WILL BE GREETED BY A AUDIENCE
THAT'S SUPPORTING HIM.
AT THE SAME TIME PUTIN AND HIS
DEFENSE MINISTER WERE IN BELARUS
ASKING FOR ASSISTANCE.
IT'S A STARK CONTRAST.
>> IT'S NOT OFTEN I GELT TO SAY
I'M HAVING A MIND MELD WITH
GREAT MEN LIKE YOU, BUT THAT'S
WHAT I WAS GOING TO BE ASK YOU
YOU, THE THE SPLIT SCREEN.
I LOVE WHEN YOU STEAL MY
THUNDER.
STEAL IT AT ANY TIME.
LET ME ASK YOU THEN, DAVID, THE
PRESIDENT IS ANNOUNCING TODAY HE
HE'S -- THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SENDING UP A MISSILE SYSTEM.
GIVEN MOW SOPHISTICATED THIS IS,
THIS IS A PRETTY EXPENSIVE WAY
TO DEFEND THEIR STRUCTURE.
IS YOUR REPORTING ABOUT THEY'RE
SEEING IT AS LESS OF WHAT THEE
DEFENDING AGAINST NOW, BUT MORE
WHAT THEY THINK OR FEAR COULD BE
COMING?
>> EXACTLY, KATE.
THEY'VE HAD TO GO DEAL WITH
INCOMING MISSILE ATTACKS, OF
COURSE, AND THEN THE
IRANIAN-SUPPLIED DRONES.
WHAT THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT IS
YOU CAN SEE RUSSIA BEGIN TO USE
MORE STRATEGIC WEAPONS.
YOU COULD SEE THEM USE IRANIAN
CRUISE MISSILES.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT YET.
IRANIAN PRECISION MISSILES AS
WELL, AND SO I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE LARGELY ABOUT THE
DEFENSE OF KYIV, THE CAPITAL.
IT'S NOT GOING TO END UP MAKING
A BIG DIFFERENCE, I THINK, TO
THOSE VARIOUS PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY WHERE YOU HAVE SEEN THE
DRONE ATTACKS.
ALSO, IT'S BEEN VERY HARD TO
COME UP WITH A PATRIOT BATTERY.
THERE AREN'T VERY MANY OF THEM,
SO I SUSPECT YOU'LL SEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT ARE ANNOUNCING
PATRIOT-LIKE SYSTEMS THEY'LL
DEPLOY AT THE SAME TIME.
THE U.S. HAS NOT WANTED TO DO
THIS ALONE.
>> GENERAL, THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS HESITANT.
I'VE HEARD FROM SOME MILITARY
ANALYSTS, THEY'RE SAYING WHY HAS
THIS NOT HAPPENED A LONG TIME
AGO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK -- WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THIS MOVE, THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT, WHAT KIND OF
RESPONSE IT WILL PROVOKE FROM
RUSSIA.
>> I KEEP DOING THIS, AND I SAY
THERE BETTER BE SOME MANAGE
EXPECTATION.
IT WILL TAKE A LONG TIME TO GET
THEM EMPLOYED, THE SOLDIERS AND
SUPPLIERS TRAINED ON IT.
I'M NOT TALKING WEEKS, I'M
TALKING MONTHS.
AS DAVID SAID, THIS AS POINT
DEFENSE SYSTEM AND THIS IS ONE
BATTERY.
THAT'S A COMPANY-LEVEL
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS BETWEEN
SIX AND EIGHT LAUNCHERS, ONE
MASSIVE CONTROL SYSTEM AND A
MASSIVE RADAR SYSTEM.
IT JUST TAKES A LOT OF TIME TO
UNDERSTAND AND USE, YET I KNOW
UKRAINE HAS PROVEN THEMSELVES TO
BE GREAT ON THE BATTLEFIELD, BUT
THEY CAN'T JUST FALL IN ON THIS
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT.
THIS PIECE OF EQUIPMENT CAN'T
MOVE AROUND.
IT'S A STATIONARY POINT DEFENSE
CAPABILITY.
I WILL ADD AGAIN TO WHAT DAVID
SAID, I THINK THIS IS A PUSH AND
WEDGE TO HAVE SENIOR AUSTIN GO
BACK TO THE RAMSTEIN GROUP AND
SAID WE PROVIDED A ONE OF A
KIND -- THERE ARE NO WEAPONS
LIKE THIS IN THE WORLD.
WE PROVIDED IN ONE OF A KIND
SYSTEM TO UKRAINE.
SOME OF YOU OTHER FOLKS BEFORE
START PONYING UP LOW AND
MEDIUM-RANGE SYSTEMS.
PATRIOT IS A DEFENSIVE WEAPON
SYSTEMS.
YOU DON'T WIN WARS ON THE
DEFENSE.
WHAT I WOULD BE LOOKING AT IS
NOT SO MUCH PATRIOT AS WHAT'S
COMING NEXT WITH THIS BIG
PACKAGE, THE CAPABILITY OF
PUTTING TOGETHER COMBINED ARMS
TEAMS TO CONDUCT OFFENSIVE
OPERATIONS BY UKRAINE IN THE
SOUTHEAST AND THE EAST,
POTENTIALLY STOPPING ANY KIND OF
AGGRESS THAT MAY COME FROM BESS
ARUSE IN T